eu tava lembrando de de quando eu era
criança que a mãe da gente Ela faz umas
coisas estranha não sei o que é Não elas
T uns ditado estranho por exemplo qu a
gente era criança elas batia na gente aí
a gente chorava um
pouquinho ela dizia não chora não quem
foi que mandou tu quebrar esse copo Quem
foi fo que não mãe eu tava pegando um
negócio aqui sem querer cair no chão
cala boca eu mandei você ficar
calado quem foi que mandou quebrar esse
copo aqui
hum hum hum Wi eu estou falando com
quem me responde quando eu falar com
você oxe mãe não foi Senhora mesmo que
disse PR ficar calado Mãe cala a boca
mãe eu não entendo era para ficar calado
ou era para falar